hey guys how's it going today I am
joined with the one we broke Oh No nerdy
nummies
she's my absolute favorite and I lived
on a bunch of videos together we also
just did one it's a gingerbread
challenge video on her channel so while
we were filming this I'm like you don't
even really cool if we need a
gingerbread Apple store yeah and here we
are attempting that making gingerbread
houses from scratch is actually very
difficult for me and I bake all the time
I usually use the kit we I should have
done that because this was just beyond
my skill level now because I didn't want
you'd have to be you're all day slaving
over a hot stove and messing things up
like I normally do I thought I would go
ahead and prep some of the items I'm
gonna go get that ISO swing and then I
want you to tell me everything I did
wrong okay be right back okay ready are
you ready yeah my first item okay this
is uh this is a gingerbread slab right
this is the banks oops oh yeah uh-huh
yeah okay let's see here this is good
I'd be very 8a plus okay might fall
apart okay
okay all right let's just we should we
just throw this on here mm-hmm sounds
good do we have a big plate to put it on
that's a great idea yeah Alex and I hate
right there that looks good maybe we can
even cover this in powdered sugar to
make it look like a horse no we can do
that oh yeah ours this no no we're good
okay this is not gonna be an edible
gingerbread house by any means no this
is gonna be a display gingerbread house
with edibles on the top yes speaking of
edibles hold on what do you got I've got
some non edible things I got some LED
light what because I felt like the Apple
store might need to have some lights in
it
oh yeah it's well lit mm-hmm so sorry
Justine I'm not a tech expert I'm just
as I'm good with baking but did I break
this now I want to show you
something that took me about 20 hours to
fail out oh no go what did you do oh oh
you guys just keep off me - mom - edible
kitchen tile sweet happy holidays here's
edible kitchen tile decorations you guys
know that we're making an edible real
house and that'd be fun if we made a
whole house that was edible look I don't
think this is edible so okay okay I see
what you did yeah I thought it was gonna
be clear but on Google it says it didn't
gets above 300 degrees Fahrenheit it
starts to caramelize and then it makes a
light ya tan a yellowish color with hard
candy there's a few tricks around this I
should have come over I should have
helped you do this I didn't want to
bother you so then I was like okay I've
got a great idea I want to just put it
in the freezer you never bother me you
should drink Oh
oh geez Russia called me home guys let
me know in the comments below you think
Justine shouldn't just give me a ring
well it is lighter yeah this one I took
out at like 240 degrees okay but then it
was too bendy so I was like wow logic
I'm gonna put it in the freezer it's
lighter look at you guys little lighter
all right what 20 hours of nonsense
looks like me you know something about
testing I'm kind of really proud of you
because this is test baking you guys
this is why I spend like 70 hours a week
doing and you're doing it when she tells
it how much time she spends like
prepping for a video hmm I was like girl
you got tests fake everything hold on
what you get what do you got over there
well I feel like it's Christmas I
couldn't find any icing so I thought
like why not just get glue gun I mean
this is already not edible cuz I didn't
even wash my hands when I started baking
this Oh
I will say another fun little food FAQ
about food styling is that people who do
like competitive gingerbread house
baking like I use hot glue guns
sometimes because the icing takes about
two to three hours to set what is
happening right now well well we are
will start at the bottom started from
the bottom now we're here and then we'll
get here okay which ones do we start
with oh god I feel like I want to cry I
feel like you big a shower with these I
got a shower tile it's so heavy it is
it's really heavy our Logan is heating
okay these him oh oh oh he's okay coming
Oh gusty now they're stuck together Oh
shoo shoo we might need Oh
oh my god I am so sorry
I'm so sorry I thought I had a handle on
that and I cannot I did not have a
handle on that
oh my gosh Oh what have I done
we have enough but it's yours
ready go lay down we have a broom I'm so
sorry
actually I didn't realize that they were
sick together Wow
I didn't know it was gonna slick yeah so
all that happened and it was amazing but
we gotta get back to business
oh my Mario I'm so sorry I feel so bad
how many awful things have happened in
this kitchen that that's like not even a
dick you know
to eat honey okay I was gonna say stir
with your first one we'll put a little
um you would put icing but we're gonna
glue your bottom
I don't just run it on the side is it
work all the way down I'm really there
you go all the way down should we also
glue it more like on inside you can glue
at the bottom or use icing we use icing
to reinforce and then when you're adding
the side you want to add them behind
oh not on the side you add it behind you
also did a gingerbread house baking tips
video too did it you know yeah I did I
did a tips video where I shared like my
favorite gingerbread making tips
everybody watch that before you attempt
anything that looks like it's starting
up more Follette oh wait a minute what
temperature did you bake this in I don't
know oh okay watch your little fingers
okay okay what's wrong you know what
what what if we did an apple gingerbread
house every year and it gets and it gets
better and better and better and better
every year we learned about things this
is almost as good as icing that's like a
broken front anything else let's just
not talk about it we don't talk about
the back what back anyway okay let's put
the tarball okay okay careful I don't
want to do it go move it you don't move
over any more because you're gonna get
glue in your in your enemy here in your
body it's do you need minute yeah I
can't trust myself because this really
slippery its sole slipper okay okay how
do we put just like that like that right
just eyeball it yeah I think it looks
good I'm not one windows cracks well the
glitter wash we did it
I would don't get too close to no
they're still worth one Justine next
year we're gonna make the clear out of
isomalt okay yeah whatever that is I'm
down candy it makes it really clear do
you think we should try to put it that
modern I'm just like now I just forget
about it I think it's just forgettable
so you know remember you like it on new
iPhone we're now the product you get
these stickers yes but we can put this
on the outside perfect put in the middle
that's what's that boom okay what do you
think about this cuz I've got these
little LED lights do you want to put one
in the ceiling or should we
behind here to illuminate the Apple logo
oh you got illuminate that Apple look at
this it's oh my gosh this is good
working it's working I need to be all
this is so great we do know we need
icing to make it look more festive okay
to make snow you can use different
things you can use powdered sugar you
can use coconut shavings or I really
like these little ice candies they're
really really - I have frosting yeah on
the blossom util the only thing
gingerbread about this house mmm is the
base is this working out why I think
it's gonna last for the holidays well
the holidays already started so
technically if it just makes it through
this video I'm gonna be happy what color
is the floor isn't an Apple store like a
light brown light brown yeah then you
should I are you some yeah okay cuz we
don't have a back so they left the door
open so it's known and so the
distributors can come bring in their
prAna's okay one a little sneak peek of
this look at this this is the inside
this is our reinforcements they left the
doors open because it was Black Friday
and they needed to put a whole bunch of
product in there did Adam they win right
now it's just for the people in back
there we go I'm getting our snow pshew
yes well I don't have anything to sift
it to make it look like snow so I'm
gonna use this when using one of the
greater a cheese grater okay I never
have heard of this technique before
we're gonna find out oh my god are you
okay the worst technique I've seen
actually I actually I gotta hand it to
you thank you
this is one really creative here do this
let me see if this works don't cut
yourself let me try it oh that's nice
tap tap Justine
this actually kind of works if you don't
have a save at home look at this snow oh
this oh yeah grab a holly jolly
Christmas Santa's coming to town he's
bad I think that they're having a sale
you know what never goes on sale
anything at the apple store okay well
you can't even see him so they'll see
matter let's put some holiday
festivities what's the best if it is on
the dock so can I do a little green cuz
we need red and green we do a Christmas
color here we go you guys this thing is
like barely hanging on like let's show
that look at the see the back it's like
falling in in but surprisingly it's
looking pretty good
the side of you guys now if you're new
here I'm obsessed with Lego and I have
tons and tons I've hundreds of LEGO
minifigures so I was going through all
of my LEGO Minifigures today to find a
perfect row Chris help you with a little
oh this is you and you've got a little
cookie and you have like a little pug
Char Dham shirt on glasses I love that
and then here's me with my player one
and my fellow my gosh Justine give me
the short legs I love that it's like
real life if there's like no shorter it
would be just like that
we're just run away I'll be over here
wait where's Maddy
oh here yes right here you have a Maddy
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm looking impressed with what we
accomplished out of what we had to work
with I and you guys little business
scholarship I heard that's it you guys
didn't know that this was also a beauty
to pile love beauty tutorials
is this a think it's it I think this is
this tada I'm sure there are some other
things that he could do to this but
honestly given what we have to work with
and the support system that I did not
account for it it looks good I think
it's so um I mean it's really bowing so
I think at a time will on it this was
the best we could do well thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed whatever you just witnessed
thank you so much for hanging out with
me thank you for having me over I'm so
sorry I added to some of the chaos today
next time I just need to like hit you up
earlier and be like girl yeah cuz what
am i doing it's bendy it's aw I was
crying all last night trying to make
guys sugar glass is no joke look at this
now I've got powdered sugar all along it
it's like a smiley face kind of looks
like this way it's on there Santa yeah
there oh my god oh ho ho Merry Christmas
thank you guys again for watching make
sure you go check out Rose channel and
be sure to check out the gingerbread
challenge video that we did yes we
decimated gingerbread houses also
chaotic this time put awesome okay
[Music]